people in the northeast who got up to
watch the sunrise
only saw part of it a rare solar eclipse
that astronomers call
a ring of fire took a bite out of the
sun for more than an
hour chief weathercaster lonnie quinn of
our new york station wcvs tv
was watching that show in the sky lonnie
it's been a long time
since we've seen this
oh yeah anthony the northeast you've got
to go back to 1959 that's before i was
born
the next one not until 2079
so uh this was my opportunity my once in
a lifetime opportunity to see it
it did not disappoint here in
connecticut we had a spectacular view of
it
about 80 percent of the sun was covered
by the moon as it was rising i mean it
was something to see
and you had all kinds of iconic pictures
around the northeast
the sun rose over that iconic new york
city skyline great shots from the jersey
shore
as well again like i said nothing was
disappointing out there
except for the fact that if you were in
boston
or if you were in michigan unfortunately
there it
was kind of clouded over because
michigan should have been the primo spot
in the united states to see it
too much cloud cover for you folks what
you had was an annular eclipse i'll
explain that in just a second but if you
were looking for
the ring of fire that you talked about
anthony you had to go to ontario canada
and they had
the ultimate show an annular eclipse
simply means the moon
is farther away so it appears smaller
and not quite big enough
to cover the entire sun so you get that
ring of fire as we
as we were referring to it but if this
whole thing has gotten you excited
about eclipse eclipses the next american
total eclipse will come on april 8th
2024 it'll start in texas it will travel
to
to maine and that will be a situation
where the daytime sky will go dark
for about four minutes but if it's the
sunrise eclipse that you're interested
in
and i think sunrise eclipses can be the
best because they're lower in the sky
right i mean they're right along the
horizon
so early on you don't need all the
special glasses because
you're looking through a lot of
atmospheres it's right on the surface
and it just it looks better out there if
you ask me
that next one is going to be 2048 in
colorado or like i said
2079 here in the northeast so for me i
think 2079 i'm going to be 115. yeah so
um
yeah you might make it
thanks